now it's like beauty week here on the
show and i was curious
when you feel the most beautiful
i think i feel the most beautiful when
i have like
a bare face um even in my sweatpants
just like
hanging out with my friends i don't know
that's when i feel like the most like
myself
and just clean and comfy okay
so i have grown up with a camera in my
face
i started at 11 months old in diapers
and
i don't think i know a life without a
camera
a camera for me is safe
it feels like a twin for me
i loved in the documentary when you went
on camera and you talked about the
breakup with your fiance
and then you came back to it hours later
bare-faced
and crying what is your relationship
with
the camera i
could never see another camera in my
life
and be okay like my twin is my voice
that's that's my twin and i for me
all i need is a room with good acoustics
or a microphone and a stage and that's
my twin
um for me the camera has always just
kind of showed up in my life
you know acting was something that i
started doing to pay for my
music lessons because my family couldn't
you know afford those without
my acting gigs and so it was just kind
of this like way to
always put money back into my music
and um
yeah i think for me all i need
is a microphone and that's what
makes me feel complete it's true it's
you
and it's your songs and i must say
that one of the things that i applaud
you for
most is not only putting your truths out
there whether it's a documentary
or you know speaking openly to people
but it's the way
you put yourself into your music it's
like
each and every song is a page from your
most beautiful
and personal book oh
thank you thank you so much
wow thank you all of my my projects like
all of my
songs are my babies right but like this
album in particular
i like to say that um this one's like my
teenager because i've gone through so
much
since the beginning of this of making
this album in 2018.
that um i've now
watched it turn into a teenager and
i've that's because i spent so much time
on it and
thank you that means a lot i i
marvel at your ability to work through
your life in your lyrics
they are so compelling oh thank you
thank you so much wow it's so true
okay as a last question is there
anything without revealing anything that
doesn't feel right to you is there
anything
that people don't already know about you
hmm i
am a blue belt in jiu jitsu what
yeah yeah it's a random fact that i like
to threat people
um i worked really hard to get it and
i'm still gonna once
once uh you know everything's good covet
free
i'm gonna pick up training again but i
love jiu-jitsu yeah
oh my god that's so cool i'm so glad i
asked
yeah me too um
i think you are so fierce i think you
are so incredible i i just i was so
excited
to talk to you there's just thank you
um you can see her documentary demi
lovato dancing with the devil
which is also her extremely personal
album it is
phenomenal word for word the documentary
is on youtube
and the powerful album dancing with the
devil
the art of starting over is the
companion piece
which is also available now thank you
demi
so so so much thank you for having me